loïs me dit je suis locataire puis-je
demander à mon propriétaire de suspendre
mon loyer est ce que c'est légal ça m
kovac bonjour bonjour pascal on va
partir du principe qu'il s'agit de ce
qu'on appelle juridiquement un bail
d'habitation
c'est à dire le lieu que vous louez pour
habiter maison ou appartement
la loi pour l'instant en tout cas
pendant la crise sanitaire ne prévoit
rien à ce niveau là donc on a
l'obligation de toujours payer son loyer
si on ne le fait pas attention on se met
en faute le propriétaire peut prendre un
huissier faire un commandement visant la
clause résolutoire dubai ça veut dire
quoi en gros ça veut dire vouloir faire
casser le bail ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que 1
vous ne serez pas expulser puisque vous
l'aurez compris il ya une trêve
hivernale qui d'habitude s'arrête en
mars qui la vallée jusqu'à jusqu'au 31
mai néanmoins rien n'interdit de prendre
contact avec le propriétaire et puis
d'essayer de négocier de lui dire voilà
je suis en arrêt maladie je perçois un
salaire moins important où je suis dos
au chômage partiel je ne touche que 84 %
de mon salaire est ce que vous seriez
d'accord pour qu'on annule mon loyer du
mois d'avril et ou du mois de mai ça
c'est tout à fait possible
les parties ont la possibilité de
négocier des termes du contrat donc
tenter ça coûte rien de le faire et puis
si votre propriétaire est sympa ça
marchera peut-être dans le cas d'un bail
j'allais dire classique pour les
particuliers maintenant pour les
professionnels qui souhaiteraient
suspendre leur loyer je pense notamment
à nos amis artisans et commerçants qui
sont particulièrement touchées pendant
cette période de confinement quels
conseils vous leur donnez vous l'avocat
m kovac pour les baux professionnels ou
les baux commerciaux pascal c'est à peu
près la même chose c'est-à-dire que l'on
doit continuer de payer son loyer
rien n'interdit de tenter de négocier
avec le propriétaire bas de repousser le
règlement des loyers ou d'annuler et si
vous êtes vraiment dans l'incapacité de
payer votre loyer je vous invite à
informer le propriétaire qui quoi qu'il
arrive parce que pour l'instant vous
êtes protégé par une loi qui a été prise
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire qui
vient dire que si vous ne réglez pas à
vos loyers pour l'instant et jusqu'à la
fin de la crise sanitaire on ne pourra
pas casser votre bail
mais ça veut pas dire que le loyer n'est
pas du cercle et pour mieux sauter il
faudra on va cumuler les loyers et après
il va falloir rassurer la dette ce qui
va être compliqué quoiqu'il arrive et
faudra payer à un moment ou un autre
exactement merci m kovac pour ces
précisions
à bientôt pour d'autres questions à
bientôt pascal bonne journée mais on
n'oublie pas en reste à la maison